hard to believe but the holiday season
is just around the corner
but if you are hoping to hear the
traditional carol or two you're out of
christmas luck
true to 2024 choral singing has now been
categorised
as a high-risk activity it's been banned
in parts of australia as it gets
droplets
everywhere in fact this year festivities
of all kinds have been paired down
for weddings and corporate events the
maximum number
is 150 but again completely seated no
dancing no singing no mingling perhaps
not the first person you'd send an
invite to
and in an unlikely turn of events the
words non-readered
woodwind instruments are hitting
headlines players now need to keep three
not the usual one and a half meters
apart
and if it's your big day but no one
sings happy birthday to you
don't take it personally children are
being encouraged to hum the tune or
listen to it on youtube instead
well that'll really get the no dancing
no mingling party
started some italian school teachers are
seizing the day
where better to share your piles of
wisdom than right
by the sea this is for sure a big
difference
especially in the time we're living in
which brings about a lot of restrictions
for children
here they experience a way of learning
that's different from what they
experience
inside a classroom living and
experiencing class outside
is obviously a plus for these children
over in germany though classes will
continue indoors
but the children's uniforms will look a
bit different they'll sport hats scarves
and coats inside and even be given
blankets
because to get the air moving windows
will be left open
and you'd better brace yourself if you
have a train to catch as they're taking
a similar approach just don't expect to
end up anywhere exotic
with all those travel restrictions in
place though if you still need that
content for instagram there are a few
options just ask the tourists who
visited japan
without ever leaving china oh there's
always photoshop
if the pandemic or trying to figure out
all those restrictions has stressed you
out
there are ways to release that bad
energy just grab your gloves
we are holding an event called the roof
tile smashing experience
it's a way for people to come and banish
their bad moods
and if you're less into tile smashing
and more into trench coats but find
matching the mask to the outfit
all a bit of a hassle designers have got
you covered
quite literally as for the hotter summer
months
there's a dress that covers you in all
the right places
original ideas in the toughest of times
innovation at its finest
and if there's one thing we can say
about 2020
it's that it's been pretty original to
say the least